and students at a Northwest High School
preparing to leave for summer break and
a bit of a sour note their banned
trailer was stolen less than a year
after raising more than thirty thousand
dollars to buy it eight news now
education reporter Joshua paguerra looks
into how it was stolen
here at Shadow Ridge High School you can
still see evidence of the crying pieces
of the trailer still scattered on the
floor leaving a lot of kids in a bind
we've had countless parents that came in
and volunteered their time their stuff
to help us get this trailer and to just
have it stolen is heartbreaking Nicole
Hub was one of those parents who put her
Blood Sweat and Tears helping Shadow
ridges Thundering Herd get this trailer
Hubble was part of a team of students
and parents who spent last summer
selling fireworks for the band program
raising more than thirty thousand
dollars Hubble says sometime between
Friday night and Monday morning it was
stolen luckily most of the band
equipment was taken out of the trailer
since band season already ended the most
important thing that's in there and it's
not a value but this year's seniors
being the first seniors got to actually
sign the trailer and each year the next
seniors will sign the trailer prior to
the trailer Hubble says the band team
rented a U-Haul truck but buying one
gave the students pride and now there's
not a Mountain High Enough a valley low
enough or a river wide enough to keep
Hubble and a band from finding it I've
got to get the trailer back I've got to
get these kids feeling positive about
this and not let people win not let the
bad guys win students will be trying to
raise funds to buy another trailer at
the intersection of Anna Decatur selling
fireworks reporting at Shadow Ridge High
School Joshua peguero eight news now